>>THE PRESS VERSUS SARA SANDSER
>>THE PRESS VERSUS SARA SANDSE
SANDSERS
SANDSER
SANDSERS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
YESTERDAY THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
BRIEFING TURNED INTO A TOTAL
FRENZY.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS IS
UP IN ARMS OVER THE DISCREPANCY
OF WHAT SHE TOLD THE PRESS
PREVIOUSLY AND WHAT GIULIANI
REVEALED THIS WEEK.
>> WHY CAN'T YOU JUST ANSWER
YES OR NO WHETHER YOU WERE IN
THE DARK?
I THINK IT'S A FAIRLY SIMPLE
QUESTION.
>> I THINK IT'S A FAIRLY SIMPLE
ANSWER.
I GAVE YOU THE BEST ANSWER I HAD
AND I'LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> HAVE WE EVER GOTTEN ANY
TRUTH OUT OF THEM?
HAVE THEY BECOME TO THE POINT
THAT THEY'VE BECOME NULL AND
VOID?
>> BUT SHE'S LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC AND I THINK SHE
NEEDS TO OWN THAT.
BEING IGNORANT AND LYING ABOUT
IT IS JUST NOT AN EXCUSE.
>> IS NO COMMENT A BETTER
OPTION?
>> IF YOU'RE JUST GOING TO LIE,
WHY BOTHER?
>> THIS IS HOW DEMOCRACY DIE
SLOWLY RIGHT IN FRONT OF US.
EVERY SINGLE DAY, DECEPTION AND
LIES BECOME NORMAL.
>> HOW DRAMATIC, MIKE.
"THIS IS HOW DEMOCRACY DIES."
OH, PLEASE.
THEN UNDER THE HEADLINE "WHY
SARA SANDERS SHOULD QUIT."
SHE LOST IT WITH THAT ANSWER.
ADMITTING THAT YOU MISLED THE
PRESS BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
MISLED YOU IS TANTAMOUNT TO
TAKING YOUR CREDIBILITY, POURING
GASOLINE ON IT, AND THEN SETTING
IT ON FIRE.
WELL, THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
LECTURE US ABOUT CREDIBILITY?
THE PRESS?
CONSIDER THE SOURCES.
OR ACTUALLY, YEAH.
ARE THESE RELIABLE SOURCES?
FOR THE MOST PART, THE WHITE
HOUSE PRESS POOL HAS BECOME A --
JUST LISTEN TO THIS.
>> SHE CAN BE MAD AT WHAT I SAY
RIGHT NOW.
TOUGH.
I'M A REPORTER WHO'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ASK QUESTIONS AND
THERE WAS NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT QUESTION.
>> I WISH I COULD INSTALL A BS
METER.
UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK IT WOULD
BE GOING OFF ALL THE TIME.
>> I ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE SARA.
I THINK SHE'S VERY RESOURCEFUL.
SHE BURNS FACTS AND USES THAT
ASH TO CREATE A SMOKY EYE.
>> THE EFFORT TO DEMEAN AND
DRIVE OUT SANDERS AND SEND HER
PACKING FROM HER JOB IS PART OF
THE POLITICS OF PERSONAL
DESTRUCTION IN THIS TOWN,
WASHINGTON, D.C.
ANYONE WHO WORKS FOR THE
PRESIDENT IS A TARGET BECAUSE
THE RESISTANCE WANTS TO THIN THE
RANKS OF THOSE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ADVANCE A
NARRATIVE OF INTERNAL DIVISION
AND CHAOS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, SARAH
SANDERS IS IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION AND HAS TO LOOK OUT FOR
HER OWN CREDIBILITY AS WELL.
SHE WAS GIVEN SCANT INFORMATION
AND REPEATED WHAT SHE WAS TOLD
IN GOOD FAITH.
ALL QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
INFORMATION SHOULD HAVE BEEN
REFERRED TO THE PRESIDENT'S
LEGAL TEAM, PERIOD.
TRUMP NEEDS A LEGAL
SPOKESPERSON, WHICH HE DOESN'T